what is up guys and welcome to the
pre-game
back on episode i don't know which one
it is but listen guys before we even get
started
like share and subscribe and if you have
watched two or more of our videos
and you haven't subscribed then we got
beef okay we got beef
right so today we are going to be
talking about something very close to my
heart guys and we're going to talk about
transgenderism um as you can see my name
is pearl
just pearly things and i have
transitioned into a handsome black man
okay six foot two
you know
why are you not laughing for me
why are you laughing you look great my
name is gotta actually emperor
it was a good transition right yes
that's what i'm trying to say so i've
got to say that man this is close to my
heart i am i am now a man um
i identify as a man a black man as a
matter of fact even though i tran i
transferred from
that from a white woman to a black man
um but
all jokes aside all jokes aside um guys
we're going to get into this show but if
we have some guests with us today
we're going to be talking about
transgenderism and before we even start
you can all go around and let them know
exactly who you are
start
is
over
everyone says everyone's identifying
themselves as pronouns these times so
i'm giving myself a saying and i'm
married and i'm happy to be on the show
i'm terence i'm from south london uh
recently just moved to
uh town speaking to the mic
yeah and um i'm not saying i'm just i'm
just a he
doing pronouns
um i'm jessica and i
live in east london
and i go by she she hurt
[Laughter]
my name's alexa um
yeah i go by
she her
how did this become oh i'm from south
london as well yeah there you go
my name is iman i'm moroccan
international student in the uk and i'm
she of course as you can see
my name is charlie sansom i'm a singer
dj and political commentator from essex
so i heard you guys um
saying your pronouns and then we're
gonna try and get a little bit more
serious because i try to you know make
it a little bit you know humorous but um
do you guys actually use pronouns
in these days and terms does anyone use
pronouns didn't anyone say i am he
referring to ourselves in referring to
yourselves yeah no no no no not at all i
say them as introductions but i work in
theater and a lot of our work is focused
on um inclusivity and so
when we introduce ourselves we start
with yeah my pronouns are she her or he
him but um in terms of just referring to
myself as i go about my business no
um do you think there's a pressure
in your industry just to piggyback off
that do you think there's a pressure to
actually use pronouns for people
i think it's quite a natural thing um
i wouldn't say there's pressure
it is definitely something i've seen on
the increase though it hasn't always
been a thing um so
so you're probably like the youngest on
the panel have you so
have you seen a change in the whole
pronoun
situation from when you were growing up
yeah like growing up it's still to this
day sometimes i have to tell myself like
beforehand okay i need to say my
pronouns because it's just not
programmed into me to do that before
like introductions especially as a
facilitator when i lead workshops or
events or things like that i have to
remind myself okay before i do this i
have to stay my pronouns um
yeah it's not it's not something i'm
used to do you guys think the pro the
pronoun thing is um creating a um
is it is it is it creating a cohesive
society or is it separating to say
definitely suffering definitely
separating society i think it's the
symptom of what we call toxic um
tolerance
whereby you're intolerant okay go on
expand on that so literally we are
so for example i joked at the beginning
when i did my introduction i'm calling
myself a saint but if i said to what if
you don't identify myself call me by my
pronoun by the way i did put up my
linkedin so i wanted to see how that
works
yeah but
if you don't call me that and i said
that your hatred that you know if you
don't identify my pronoun identifiers
that means you should be counseled or
you are disrespectful i think that's
that's crossing the line you see because
i think it's it's it's so interesting to
see what alexa is saying that you feel
that you have to identify to do it then
you're 18 so by this time you should be
it should be natural towards you but
you're finding it difficult so if you're
18 and you're finding it difficult let
alone someone that's not had these
things i'm nearly 40 now
how difficult is going to be now and i
think
what we've created now in our society's
landfills now whereby even if you're for
all this transgenderism and stuff like
that if i don't say the right prone now
i could get counseled i mean come on no
one can live up to these rules now
because jk rowling
you know she got quote unquote cancelled
because she wouldn't because she said
some stuff against a um
transgender community do you think do
you guys think the transgender community
is becoming a little bit bullish
like
they're bullying people to say the
things that they want them to say well
for me it's completely unnatural it's
not even grammatically correct to go
into a situation and go higher my name
is charlie i'm he him because when would
you say that to my face
like it's a these are third-person
terms yeah you know if i referred to you
and you weren't here
hi he got right on my nerves a minute
ago do you know what i mean i wouldn't
say it to his face sarah he got on my
nerves because it wouldn't make no sense
so for me
i just don't see the point of it i think
it's a
you've got a victimhood mentality with
it i don't actually think it's like
a genuine thing anymore i think it's
been
so exaggerated and embellished by people
that want to play this whole woke
politics yeah yeah that you can't
actually get away from it now because if
you don't do it you're a bad guy if you
do do it you're playing the game
i don't play it i don't care personally
i'm not disrespectful to people in
general but if someone says to me you
have to call me this that or the other i
don't have to yeah yeah it's scary
because it's like um i think kevin
summers once said this that
you can either use words to express
reality
or create reality
before words were used to express how
the word works but now we're just using
all these like you mentioned about it
doesn't even make any grammatical sense
calling someone by the third person
we're using to correct reality so if i
say okay if i say a certain word so if i
call myself i'm a super saiyan referring
to a dragon ball z character does that
make it reality for me
that's where we're going to end
ourselves destroying ourselves because
there's only so much toxic tolerance you
can take
new word i also i like that that's good
sorry guys that's good i also think i
think the biggest challenge that i face
when it comes to language is kind of
just knowing what to say and what not to
say i think a lot of the times you will
see on social media people talk about
okay you don't use these words or you
should use these words but everyone has
different preferences and
as someone who speaks a lot in public
it's hard for me to know what words and
what not to use because as some way or
another i will always offend someone
yeah and it's just kind of difficult
finding that balancing personally that's
something i would say do you think
someone's always going to be offended
yes yes 100 because we are different and
at some point you need to realize that
you wouldn't please anyone would you
words someone would definitely feel
offended at some point for example we
can just take it from where i come from
there's no maybe there is a community
who is transgender but they're not out
you can't see them in the streets
otherwise where'd you come from morocco
so it's an arab country right so
whatever is shown in the streets
is
whatever is actually should be shown
from an arab country because if you are
like a transgender you can't just come
out in the streets and be like i'm
transgender otherwise you'll be beaten
up you know it's that serious so for me
for example if you i don't have to to
say i'm she or or he or whatever because
i look like a she right so in morocco
it's i am a she do you look like a she
yeah i mean
i mean like long hair and features etc
that's what i meant right
and in a sense that
you you can't just give yourself another
pronoun
in a country like that because that's
that's what you're meant to be even if
you are addressing yourself as someone
else you know so
for coming from a country like that
you can't just come out
and just say that i'm a transgender
because yeah do you think those laws are
okay
it's not okay completely not because
people who are from that community are
feeling like so oppressed they're not
feeling completely free to express
themselves like they don't even feel
that they're needed in the country you
know they feel that okay we can't even
go out because it's a taboo and my
family has disowned me there are so many
transgenders who came out in the social
media saying that my family has disowned
me i don't have anywhere to go because
this is who i am this is what i am and
even if they go their friends are not
accepting them and no one basically is
accepting them except
that like people like them if that makes
sense right because they would be like
most most of the times families would
just be like oh i did something wrong
that i got a child like you and they
just feel that
what is wrong with me i'm not some like
i'm not doing something wrong to deserve
this kind of like
behavior this kind of you know so
i believe that we really need to work
hard for people to be accepted that way
especially in a country like morocco who
is a completely arab country there's not
like in between either you or she either
you're he nothing in between so it's
very hard to get that acceptance out so
do you actually believe that there's
something in between
um what i believe is
since we are in this generation and this
we're evolving day by day people can
address themselves differently it is it
is it is acceptable like maybe people
would not accept you the way you are but
you are still different you know
maybe you have something else that other
people don't have so there is something
definitely in between that that's why
people are having it it just can't come
out of the blues right there is
something in between that's why people
are addressing themselves that way but
the acceptance would definitely be
different because not everyone would be
pleased with however you are or whatever
you bring to the community
i think the problem is is our language
you see because the definition of the
classical definition of tolerance was
okay i may not agree with you but we can
live together side by side right the
problem is is that you know we
interchange words so we're thinking
because tolerance was always okay i'm
christian someone's muslim we're not we
not agree philosophically but we are
we're still neighbors we still probably
support the same football team and we're
not going to say i'm going to go to your
employees and say you're a muslim you
should be counseled or expect a muslim
to go to my employee or he said this so
he should be counseled you live side by
side i think the problem is is our
language even what the sister
the girl was saying is about acceptance
you know just because i don't accept
something doesn't mean i'm not tolerant
of something so for example if you went
to a neighbor's
house and had dinner you may not like it
but you eat it because you have to
tolerate it because you want to keep the
social cohesion so i think just what
it's a matter of the language that we we
use and like i mentioned earlier we're
using language to create a forced
reality except expressing what actually
is and that's where the problem is you
sound like you're going to say something
i agree what you said i agree what you
said there i agreed a lot that i think
that people do
accept
you may not accept certain things but
you tolerate them for sure
and i think in a country
like morocco and i don't mean this
disrespectfully
but there's a different
there's a different culture there's also
a different
um
a gdp there like the uk is far richer
therefore
in richer countries you find more of
these kinds of problems where you have
social breakdowns and i think that
in countries that are poorer
they don't have time for this kind of
mess
if i'm completely honest
because they're struggling to pay bills
or get food or get their kids a doctor
here
abby's biggest complaint most of the
time is the train was late yeah so
you're saying like transgenderism is
like a first world problem 100
100 where do you find this in other than
first world countries
sorry
yeah i was agreeing because um
it's a it's a big thing in the states um
transgender um and it's just been
interesting to see how like things have
changed over the year
and over the years and when it comes to
just different pronouns and everything
it makes speaking to people hard
because you're now you're worried about
okay
am i going to say the wrong pronouns am
i going to mistake them for
who they identify as are they gonna take
offense that are they gonna not take
offense to it so it's just like there's
so many more stipulations when just
talking to people in general because
even people who aren't transgender use
as pronouns and so you got to ask
everybody it's just uh it's just weird
and different
i don't know sorry all right i have a
question when am i talking about
tolerance i agree with that but i think
my question is how how far do we go with
this tolerance because there's been a
scenario i don't know if you guys have
heard but um apparently they're trying
some like
i've seen a post somewhere where it says
that um
all women are allowed into everyone who
identifies as a woman is allowed to go
into um this bathroom you are not
allowed to debate
them declaring themselves as a woman and
that can become very dangerous not just
for women but men like either way it's
very dangerous because um
i remember during 2020 the 2020 lockdown
there was a video going around an
american video where there was a spa
right in america somewhere and there was
a map there was a man with a penis right
you identified as a woman he was in the
female sauna
right and he identifies a woman and the
lady there was a mother in there with
her 12 year old daughter right and she
said this guy she came out ranting like
this is walking around with his penis
hanging out right but she was saying
the the the um the people that ran the
sauna were saying they identify as a
woman and she was saying my 12 year old
daughter is in this sauna with a guy
that's got his penis swinging around i
remember this do you remember it i
remember this video yeah yeah you have
to be somewhat
some
somewhat transitioning to be able to
fully identify no no that's the thing
that's what the the poster said self id
the post the poster said if you identify
as a woman your identity cannot be
challenged
this is the ridiculousness of the whole
debate because
now you can all see
i hope that i'm a man yeah and i'm not
like a woman
i'm a white man right if i said to you
guys right now i identify as a black
woman
how many of you in the room are
accepting me right now for that
statement would you accept me for that
would you would you
but just because it's socially not
acceptable now who's to say in five
years time
it's ridiculous but that's the social
acceptance is a bit
it's it's a bit ridiculous
but remember you see you're saying that
right remember you don't remember rachel
dolezal right yeah so rachel doesn't was
the black was the white woman right who
entered the naacp as a white woman who
identified as black and then she said
listen because i identify as black she
well she didn't even tell people that
she
she put on a costume
yeah she put on a costume to look black
she done her hair in braids she tanned
her skin and people believed that she
was black however she was white right
and so she said in an interview she
identifies more with being black like
charlie was saying
would you accept that the bottom line is
trans
is now getting out of the gender because
she identifies as trans racial yeah is
there
such thing as being transracial i don't
think there is yeah but but the problem
is is like i mentioned before you're
using words to correct reality who's the
same five years time if you were to say
that they'll call you a transracial folk
they can call me a transgressional phone
yeah it just doesn't make sense that is
something like you physically
says who
but i'm intolerant but i think this is
why
these debates are so important
i think his point is if you look at how
society like 30 years ago and someone
has told you that transgender was a
thing
people would react the same way as you
and there are probably still people in
this world who do react that way so i
guess his point is um yeah like we can
say this now but who knows that in the
future that could end up being socially
acceptable and i think with that right
with the whole rachel dolezal situation
like it negates the black experience
right because it's like
it's that i'm a white woman
and black people have had an experience
just like korean people have had an
experience just like chinese people have
an experience
if i now say i'm i identify as a chinese
man
moroccan people have had an experience
right yeah if i say oh no i'm a rocking
man right now like you're gonna be like
yo bro are you taking the are you taking
a piss like are you seriously taking a
piss like and it's like that's where
we've got to so when it comes to
transgenderism
uh women
have an experience in the world as a man
i don't fully know what that experience
is because i can't i don't know what it
is to be a woman however
this is gonna be this is a question do
you think transgenderism
is the epitome
of white male privilege
or
ultimate form of the ultimate form of
misogyny and the reason no go on things
go on don't know the reason why i'll
i'll preface it yeah so the reason why i
say that is because the transgender
movement right
is pushed by
mostly
white men
who i are now saying i'm gonna be a
woman yeah right i'm going to be a woman
now right and so i've always used the
analogy of the captain philip i don't
think captain phillips yes right when he
says i'm the captain now yeah like men
are saying i'm your gender man
okay do you know what i mean you know
what i'm saying it's like
but the thing is it's not a black male
thing
it's a white it's it's for me it's
patriarchy
if you want to talk about patriarchy
it's patriarchy 101 the fact that i can
go into your gender i can hijack
everything and i'm now going to hijack
your whole gender and look in your face
and say yeah it's mine now and it's fine
and what happens is it's a raisin do you
know what that was going on
i'll take hundreds of the the white
privilege because yeah i don't actually
believe in white privilege okay really i
don't know
and i i know okay i can back it up i can
back it up with you know my own takes on
i think society but okay um
i forgot the point i was trying to make
now what did you do
no because is is transgenderism the
epitome of white male privilege
because black male black men generally
chinese men generally arab men generally
you couldn't go into a whole gender and
say your gender is mine now i mean i see
your point i see your point because when
um bruce jenner decided to transition to
become caitlyn jenner
within nine months
earlier you know he was woman of the
year yeah and i thought to myself how
disrespectful to women yeah you know
there's millions
millions and millions of american women
that have lived their whole life as a
woman yeah
and
this person has decided for less than a
year to say you know what i fancy a go
yeah you know
i could keep my beard grow my hair yeah
go to the surgeon have a little have a
little fix up yeah and ain't washing
though yeah to throw your bone on the
white privilege thing i don't think
using the word white privilege helps the
conversation and i'll tell you why
because once that you insert white and
privileged you're assuming saying that
every white person
has this
um what we say is i'll probably say it's
majority privilege or majority advantage
it's probably a better term yeah than
using white prick i think those
two words
stirs up so much negative connotation
because
our white brothers and sisters
sometimes feel attacked if they say you
got white privilege i think it's the way
it's used sometimes i get the concept
that
white people are the majority
demographic in this country so you have
a there's an advantage similar if i went
to china people in china would have a
chinese people yeah it's majority
demographics yeah for sure i think the
better term is called majority privilege
than saying why you're looking like you
know i agree over there bro i just think
privileges are i'm just trying to try to
find them from them because i think
sometimes using the word white privilege
yeah we understand what we mean yeah but
to them they don't understand and this
is where we get lost in our translation
you see yeah so if i'm safe we want to
build like cohesive conversation using
the term that they don't they don't
emotionally
it's helpful
i've heard this argument before and i
feel you but when you look at
let's say for example
barack obama's daughters right yeah
and you've got like a white
family yeah they're crackheads they've
got no money their kids addicted on
birth who's got a privilege at birth
barack obama's kids that's not a good
example of course it's a good example
because because you think white food is
at birth right yeah white prison is that
birth
that cracker then i'm going to privilege
over barack obama's children but white
privilege doesn't doesn't mean there's
black people can't be wealthy didn't say
that nobody say that using that example
me is it's an extreme polarity
yeah i understand i understand where
you're going with that but i'm just
saying it's not a good example because
he's a president and he how did he get
there white privilege in america
white privilege again doesn't mean well
hold on
is it not a hold up is it not is it not
given us like a hold up to black people
or anyone who isn't white
the most powerful man in the world was a
black man
for eight years running and given the
demographics of america more white
people voted for him than black yeah so
where's the privilege there's there's
definitely there's no privilege there i
think he wouldn't have won
he wouldn't have won look at even uk
politics look at the cabinet white
privilege doesn't mean i hate black
people so no i'm not saying that i'm
just saying that there's no there's no
barrier to progression yeah anymore i
get historically there would have been
but in today's country what can you do
that i can't what can i do that you
can't it's not about the abilities about
the opportunity
what okay opportunities are limited to
you you can do something i can't it's
it's that if you grow up you could get a
job over me because you're black
in many in many professions you would
you would of course you would because
it's because it's positive
discrimination these days or
affirmations so you can see the reason
why when you use that word white
privilege you see already the how about
crossfire
each other you see so we're talking at
each other and talking to each other you
see i respect you i respect your view oh
yeah yeah
yeah yeah but
i just don't i just don't think that you
can let's put it this way with what i do
like i'm self-employed i sing a dj right
i get all my own work yeah yeah but for
my politics i used to work for the
conservative party i'm well known for
doing that
if i was to go for a job yeah as a paye
person yeah i'd never get employed yeah
because i've got views
that are not concurrent with what's
acceptable to my race yeah right but if
you guys said yeah white privilege i'm
trans i'm gay you got you ceo yeah i say
to see it from uh from the from the
black point of view in terms of he talks
about because the laws there's no laws
to say no black person can apply for a
certain job it's a bit like just because
the laws have a race doesn't mean the
effects of those ancient laws are not in
existence exactly so it's a bit like the
when the earthquake happens what does
the most damage it's not the initial
earthquake it's the aftershocks
so the sometimes the
disadvantages that black people may
receive it's not necessarily the laws
that are currently on the books it's the
aftershocks of what was there prior to
that you see so
yeah so there's
it's
oranges and apples here so there's
points that as the black community that
we can state but
like i mentioned using the word white
privilege i don't think it helps the
conversation i understand yeah yeah so i
think it is in the world in the day we
want a constructive
uh dialogue not just talking about each
other and i feel when we use the word
white privilege all it is
white people just feel attacked and it
doesn't get anywhere
and they would say oh you people are
victims all the time there's no law that
says that black people can't get certain
jobs yes but they don't sometimes
realize it's the after effects that us
what's something that's holding us back
does anyone bring it back to the
argument no i i enjoyed i enjoyed this
kind of conversation about night um but
bringing it back to the actual uh
argument um does anyone know what gender
dysphoria actually is
yeah it's a mental
uh
i won't say deficiency but
that's what i do but
yeah i know
yeah i remember watching somebody who's
a transgender woman describing what it
was so according to the nhs i'm going to
read it out right so it says gender
dysphoria is a term that describes a
sense of unease
that a person may have because of a
mismatch between their biological sex
and their gender identity
this sense of unease or dissatisfaction
may be also
so it may be so intense that it can lead
to depression anxiety
and have a harmful impact on daily life
so that's according to the nhs
right
so
gender dysphoria
is an unease according to
you know the the the nhs it is a
an ease of
feeling something
so my question is when it comes to
transgenderism
is it a feeling
yeah
i would say so yeah i believe so i
wasn't feeling sorry for one second
because um otherwise why would someone
choose to just
switch to the other sex right they feel
something that is and that's making them
feel uneasy on their own skin otherwise
they wouldn't have just changed it right
why would they just go through that
whole trauma going against whatever they
feel as nature right and then go through
like go through comments harsh comments
for no reason they are feeling something
that is making them go through that
transformation right so i would
definitely believe it's a feeling of
unease that's making someone take that
decision or maybe a drastic decision of
just transforming it so when did so my
whole question now becomes when did a
feeling
i agree with the question that sounds so
weird i agree with that question because
the the thing that's coming in my head
is that there has been
children as young as 12 13
really push forward on getting their
gender changed or sex changed and it's
like
is that okay is it okay for someone as
young as 12 or 13 to come out and say
yeah i'm changing my sex i'm going to
identify as someone else where does that
feeling begin
um
yeah but i feel like i feel like i feel
like if if if you feel like your
feelings
if somebody feels like they are that
they they identify more with the
opposite sex i don't have a problem with
it that's how you feel
i don't have
if that's how you feel that's how you
feel you know like if you wake up and
you feel happy you feel sad you feel you
know whatever and if there is a means to
achieve whatever it is you feel then go
for it but
when it comes to kids like you said you
can't allow kids to
say how they feel and then act on it
because
the kids you're going to try and say but
if it's a fully grown adult and you know
exactly what what you want from your
life
and you feel like you're you identify as
a woman or a man or whatever it is i
feel like there's nothing wrong with
that
but i believe if sorry if it keeps
persistent for example so their kids and
they're still growing the feeling keeps
persistent yeah then there's definitely
something wrong right yeah if the if the
end like if the uneasy feeling keeps
growing inside them
yeah then when you're an adult when
you're an adult then you can do whatever
it is if there is a means to achieve it
i feel like i think if you break it down
into this though it's it's it's syncing
between what's in your mind and your
body yeah now the question is and this
is it just fundamentally is the issue
if there's
something out of sync between your mind
and your body did we treat the mind or
do we treat the body
like for example there is a i can't
remember the exact um
mental condition it is but there's
people that are fully abled but they
identify themselves as crippled they're
called jesus called trans able thank you
thank you and they want to literally
amputate their legs yes did we allow
that to happen as a society yes if
someone's yeah do they want that yes
because that's where the site is going i
don't agree with it but that's what
society will do they that's society are
attending to
uh
in this days and times they are saying
because you feel a certain way we are
going to accommodate your feelings okay
and so
because you feel this way
the if somebody feels like if a man
feels like a woman or a woman feels like
a man
the
what we are going to do we are not going
to treat you mentally we are going to
change your physical so you feel better
about yourself
and that's what society's doing yeah but
that's intolerance
[Applause]
hold on because if women can get boob
jobs and you can get lip fillers and
stuff like that what's that bruh where's
the light seriously
if a woman feels like she wants to
enhance how she looks she can if a male
wants to he can peter andre with his
enhancements whatever it is
what is the difference
i can give you a difference um the
difference in this scenario is uh
transgender
the actual movement is affecting society
and not just the individual themselves
so if a woman gets a boob job as such
right that's a something that you could
say necessarily it's for herself and yes
it may have imp impacts on other people
but
it is effective to say you know you
think it's super political
you think that kim kardashian's
job affected just herself or did it
affect a society no that's like on the
frog no that that's true that's true
yeah it's true but we we can choose to
view her content whereas with the
transgender movement
i can't choose not to play someone in a
sport yeah is a biological male
um yeah because they identify as being
female i just yeah but sorry go ahead
sorry guys i'm sorry i just think there
must be a line drawn somewhere like
you're telling me a man nowadays can get
pregnant
huh
hold on i think the line has to be with
terminology because if like i say if
you're if you're a man and you want to
transition to a woman that's fine but
you can't participate in biological
women's sports so you can do what you
want but and where you said it affects
society
society shouldn't allow those
individuals to affect society
essentially because allowing a man to
participate in a biological woman's
sport because you're now a transitioned
woman
it doesn't make sense what what a less
schedule sorry
alexa just said right
was
segment segwaying me onto what
congressman
congressman dan bishop recently said
right they were in congress
right and there were two medical doctors
sat down and he asked the question
what is a woman
to a medical doctor right and the
medical doctor says
whatever you identify as congressman dan
bishop
said
can a man get pregnant and have an
abortion
the medical doctor said
yes yes the reason why i saw this and
the reason for this is is fear
medical professionals literally
um because of their backlash they
literally have to lie
sorry one second
the medical professional knows what they
said is bs but they realize if i say the
truth i'm going to get a backlash on
social media so i have to lie which
explains to you why
totalitarianism can happen because
you're scared of the consequences if i
speak the truth i'm going to lose my
career and then rather people are more
more comfortable with comfortable lies
than the harsh truth sorry you were
saying sorry go on jesse this is
congressman from um america's dan bishop
okay i thought so yeah yeah
come back to me because
you were gonna say something you were
saying your mind is blown yeah actually
because um
it's just something like maybe i can i
could say against the natural you know
if if like a doctor actually says that
just imagine how many people would just
react to it i mean i'm just talking from
a perspective of my own ethnicity right
like if you go to an arab country and
just say that yeah a man can get
pregnant now and can choose to do
abortion two things that is very
controversial in an arab country people
just lose their minds you know
it's important to understand the context
of that conversation the context was he
was in a courtroom yes
under like testimony on oath and he had
to give a statement that would have had
direct implications on his job no no dan
bishop was a congressman asking the
medical doctors a question there were
two female medical doctors okay and he's
female female medical doctors
okay and he asks the female medical
doctors
what is a woman so that's even worse
so women are now saying we don't know
what a woman is and he asked the woman
can men get pregnant and have abortions
she said
yes
wow that's the thing exactly that's what
context creating you know using words
look it up folks
congressman dan
bishop right okay go on go on youtube
and look up
um congressman dan bishop okay and see
what happens you will see the female
medical doctor say yes
it's sad because
those two questions are very simple easy
questions to answer but the fact that
i feel like common sense amongst people
across the world has gotten less and
less yes that should be just a common
sense answer a woman this is what
a woman you need to be a woman and then
no a man cannot have a get pregnant or
get an abortion because it's physically
impossible there's just nothing yeah but
no it's not men can get pregnant the
doctors are responsible men can have
periods they can't oh
no as per today's society because that
oh i'm like
yeah speaking of the mind sorry yeah men
can have periods yeah is this
is so frustrating i had mine yesterday i
just come off
i'm pale you see you see so you know i
can have my
listen respect my pronouns okay see you
could if technically if you did
transition
and
and you were still
biologically
a
female but you identify as a man that's
where you can say yeah i'm a man i can
still get pregnant and
have a period but it's like
biologically you're still a woman and
that's where what do you think the end
goal is yeah i think the issue is i
think it's it's
it's definitely the doctors don't know
what they're doing it's cowardice i
agree they they're scared of the
backlash but we've had that across the
whole pandemic as well yeah people are
scared yeah they're scared of they're
just scared of if i say the truth now
i'm going to lose my job i'm more afraid
hence why we'll believe you know like i
said sweet lies then the harsh truth but
it for but not for a fact if she was in
the operating theater she's going to be
very very black and white this is a male
this is why i need to give this male
this is a female this one is female
there's not going to be no transgender
argument because if you give a female
dose a male dose to a female body that
person could die and even differently if
you commit a crime and you leave your
dna at the scene of the crime they're
not going to be like oh
they're going to be like oh this was a
man at the scene of the crime because
but right but she identifies as a woman
is that and imagine you were in court
you were like that can't be me because
i'm a woman yeah
that's not my idea it only adds
confusion on yeah yeah so how confused
that you were saying what's the end goal
i don't know i mean i'd love to know the
answer because it seems to me there's a
connection between politics and business
and i've not quite worked out how this
is profitable
because
no one that i speak to about this
thinks this is normal yes yeah when you
turn on the tv yeah it's portrayed as
normal yeah by these people speaking out
though they're scared to speak out
because they lose their jobs because
they've got mortgages to pay like when
when you see some like especially the
trans demographic say they're
underrepresented they're mistreated
they're not accepted in society
you can go to any government building
over the next month and you'll see
rainbow flags yeah i've seen
rainbow flags zebra crossings i've seen
rainbow flag police cars even riley in
essex which is not exactly you know like
the most liberal of places
to be fair with you yeah it's a very
conservative county
um
there's rainbow police cars and i'm
looking at that going
how much did that cost for you guys to
be wrong yeah you know for real how much
does that cost you to spray the cars or
get the vinyl stickers i don't know what
it is but
like why are you doing this because the
police is not there to make political
statements it's there to be impartial it
should be it's not anymore but then
where is the political advice who's this
who's funding it exactly but also and
what's the final result of it is it i
think personally i think the final
result is to make the society more
weaker so even though we know it's wrong
but we realize if we speak her we could
lose there's going to be big
consequences well yeah i mean if you
think about it if you if what cyrus said
earlier on about men
transitioning to be wounded
and it is mainly men doing it
there aren't any real men left around to
stick up for the rest of society you
know it goes back to that moment what do
you mean real men what's a real man yeah
one of a penis
i'm not afraid to say that
i'm not afraid but it's true
you kind of get it's like
the beta tization if that's even a word
of society
you know because you get like you said
men aren't afraid aren't allowed to
speak up if you speak up you lose your
job i've known political commentators
and people that are on youtube people in
america politicians that have lost
access to their bank accounts because
they've said the wrong thing at the
wrong time in front of the wrong person
and it's gone around the internet yeah
they've got no money now they can't make
no money yeah they can't have access to
their bank they can't pay their bills
that's not fair yeah
and you haven't you haven't permeated
society in schools as well
where children are being suspended from
schools for saying
what's the transgender bit i don't i
don't get it
we're actually gonna we're actually
gonna get into that but before we do
um we've got some super chats guys
you've actually got some super chats um
warren lee
donated 199. he said
for your camera fund thank you very much
thank you very much
this was from um
yes um
wednesdays oh is it thursday's uh live
oh i've got two of those so warren lee
and nigem nine gmail energy miller yeah
ten dollars okay okay so this from okay
cool um there was a study in america
that i can give the link to the intp
women and
isfj men typically got into
relationships 93 percent of them
according to the study this is masculine
women and femme men so that was from the
last
okay so let's read today's ones from
boss
to pound to super chat i identify as
chocolate my pronoun
my pronouns are her and she's
god that's hard
yeah nice that's right
both uh five pound superchat says
the two black gentlemen who claim white
privilege exist do they think black
privilege exists and if so how can we
possibly balance privilege
um interesting tim byanna 199
uh no just downloaded no no no no
comment thank you very much
uh ryan acorn five dollars poor one out
for kevin samuels man timed it right he
was born naked and died naked
okay
fw ict tv
499 says let's talk about how modern
women is fighting the
lbgtxyz to be replaced in the modern
world and in the future hashtag
the bots are coming
okay
all right so
before that
before we carry on
thank everyone for the super chat uh
going towards new equipment we really
appreciate it paul really appreciates it
and she'll be back um june 2nd so she
will be back june 2nd so i will be
transitioning back
i will be transitioning back
come june 2nd okay
listen i'm telling you listen it was
just it was just like uh it's an
experiment to see where was that how do
you feel in the new body um do you know
what it is i've never had a penis before
so like it's like it's amazing right
okay i've only used it a couple of times
but you know i'm like
only a couple of times but you know i
will be back june 2nd guys as pearl
um
anyway let's continue on um
right so we were talking about
i was going to say when it comes to the
transgender movement it's now being
pushed in schools
right
and how do we feel about
transgenderism being pushed on children
it's ridiculous
like children don't need to i mean
children can feel however they alvarez
they want to speak into the mind but
children's minds change they're not
mentally capable to make any decisions
about their bodies in a long time i feel
like it's ridiculous i mean it i feel
like it may be helpful for
acceptance of you know
the society you know maybe to educate
them a little bit but
i feel like it's going to do more harm
than good
but what gets me annoyed about is just
like kids are struggling to read and
write and do basic arithmetic and stuff
like that but yeah we're spending all
our time teaching about relationships at
such a such a young age you know and
stuff like that i think let kids enjoy
their childhood yeah you know at some
point it has to be at some point when
they're about maybe
10 11 12 they talk about what happens in
life some people identify as gay some
people identify as lesbian people as
trans
you know but you still have to respect
them if you don't agree with them teach
about diplomacy about just because you
disagree with someone doesn't mean that
you disagree doesn't mean that you
disagree are bored that you want them
cancelled and know how to tolerate one
another but now we're just teaching oh
someone identifies this
is what it's going to be i remember this
though and this confession i'm going to
make i remember when i was a kid
i so want to identify as michael jackson
yeah yeah
which version was very i wanted to
yeah but if that was the case does that
mean that i had to bleach my skin
and um pull my hair yeah charlie's close
to the mark with michael jackson
yeah yeah but my parents would have said
i would have told my parents
mom if you don't allow me to bleach my
skin
and pearl my hair you're being unloving
and i did i think i was michael jackson
when i was five but like anything else
you grow out of it yeah yeah i think me
personally i think when it comes to
teaching young people about this
i think
as much as teachers can say they're
neutral and they're not biased i feel a
lot of times the teaching will come
across as encouragement rather than
actual education and it's like
young young people can be very very
easily influenced yeah if a child like a
child can see something on tv they're
thinking oh yeah that's true that looks
great they go into school they see okay
um
perhaps um i would look better as a man
yeah you know what that's actually true
maybe i would yeah oh i would look
better as a woman okay let me put on a
wig oh yeah i put on my mom's wig and it
worked out really really well like yeah
i think i should do that i feel like
that there would be a line between
actual education and encouragement and
it's hard to balance that line so yeah
yeah another thing that happens is when
someone does identify themselves as
trans of the child they get so much
ammunition
admiration that it feels their ego
exactly so for example if i was a
five-year-old or six-year-old then came
out i'm a girl now all of a sudden
everyone's saying you're so brave you're
this bbc is contacting you obama's
contacting you everyone the prime
minister's contact you say how brave you
are all of a sudden now that goes into
your head you figured well he got the
information maybe i should do it it's a
social contagion
yeah it makes sense
called libs of tick-tock yes i have yes
no you never come across that she got
she got she recently got docked
absolutely
could you say that again
libs of tick tock
l-i-b-s l-i-b-s of tick-tock
because
what they do is they kind of aggregate a
lot of videos that people post
um
basically it's transgender teachers
going into school confessing that they
have come out to their school kids and
how it was a euphoric experience for
them and how the kids have got their
pronouns correct and how some of their
kids have crossed them now and said they
want to be transgender and i think to
myself
did they think that before you said that
because the way i look at it is
uh which one of you here said that kids
are impressionable me you you're
absolutely spot-on i'm a dad
sarah's a dad
chat about this like off camera before i
walked in the room
and
i think that
when you're screaming it it is in a way
it is in a way i don't think it's like i
don't i actually don't think it's that
malicious actually i think that some
something like the worst one because
it's the sheep's clothing malicious
because you're coming across as very
loving giving the sweeties but you know
yeah trojan horse kind of militia yeah
yeah it is even worse yeah but the thing
is
i've got no problem with people being
lesbian girl bisexual because i can
i can understand that in my mind it's
basic physical attraction
relationship dynamics we all know how
they work
but when you can't explain something and
you tell a kid that's normal
and the kid believes that postman pat is
real at the same time where are you
going with this conversation with the
child yeah you know when i was a kid i
loved power rangers
you know what i mean
yeah right
i was a black power ranger
yeah that was a rare one yeah but the
point is that when when you listen when
you watch these shows as a kid you kind
of get engrossed in the imagination of
it all you do yes and if you would let
your kid cross the road on their own go
to the shop on their own yes you know
they kind of wipe their bum on their own
can they really transition and
i want to ask you guys a question is is
it child abuse
is it child abuse
because you're implanting thoughts into
their head when they're impressionable
because as a child you see every adult
as a god figure anything they say has to
be true i remember my mom saying to me
that if i don't sleep at eight o'clock
some
deep uh thing available will come and um
you know torture me that gave me
nightmares yeah so so imagine says oh
because you like teddy bears oh you're
like i like care bears by the way when i
was a kid confession does that mean
you're very good oh you like care bears
do you maybe you're a girl
and i'm saying maybe i am
so i'm saying how impressionable you are
you're right i think it's grooming
yeah yeah i think john rogan said it
didn't he but i think some of these
people do you think they're doing
something good which is which is where
you get that
you get the debate when they actually
feel they're doing something positive to
help children
when i don't see it as a positive in any
way shape or form well the thing is you
talk about children there are two people
that i want to talk about specifically
that actually have trans children right
so
um dwight zimmern or dwyane wade
dwyane
basketballer his son has now
transitioned into a girl
and i forget her name but his name her
name see i'm offending people already um
his name her name she's transitioned to
a girl and also charlie thuron
charlie saron
um
adopted a boy
from somewhere in africa
and she said at the age of five or six
he said to her
i don't feel like a
a boy a mummy i feel like i'm a girl and
now if you were to look at pictures of
when she adopted him as to
now he's a whole he's a whole girl right
and this is like she's got him in like
blonde wigs and all and all kinds of
stuff do you know what i mean so um the
trans
child thing is also um a thing and it's
like they're allowing children
to make decisions at such a young age
that are going to affect the rest of
their lives and now it's like how do we
allow a child to make such a decision
it's very harmful yeah i don't think you
do but i do think there should be
room left for queerness i think i think
it was you who mentioned earlier where
you said if a child consistently that
persists that this is how they believe
and if as they grow older they grow in
that unease then that's a different
thing
and i think there should be room and
scope for them to allow them to explore
who they are um
but i don't think it's fair that young
people actually make that decision yeah
as a child exactly i mean i believe it's
harmful actually just imagine how how
many questions a kid actually grow in
their minds when you add so much
confusion in it like by just bringing
this topic which is transgenderism right
they would just have more questions to
ask they would get even more confused
today i feel like a girl tomorrow i feel
like a guy
how like just because i like pink for
example they would be like oh yeah today
i'm a girl tomorrow night i would like
for example powering just no i'm a guy
you know it's just like it's it's
different it's like you you grow more
confusion into a kid they're not in a
position to take decisions like that
that's why i bring back home schooling
baby
even with that
there's so much that
the kids have access to that they're
going to find out about it and have
their own idea about it so i don't think
it should be taught in school because of
it just being everywhere for them to
have access to and you may never know if
a kid is being homeschooled how they
search up their answers for their
homework or information for their
homework they may see something pop up
and then go down and grab a hole of
society's own thoughts of whatever it is
that they're looking up so i don't think
that
there's no way of hiding anything
from kids nowadays unless you they're
not in touch with the outside world at
all so they're going to find out about
it some way or another
yes it is
it is a dilemma because if you become an
authoritarian parent and literally block
everything off
sooner or later once they turn 16
they're going to rebel exactly the same
you find that with very very
conservative parents who raised their
kids very conservatively they become the
biggest rebellion because they just feel
no i'm free exactly yeah i've got
freedom now yeah it's funny you talk
about conservatives though um do you
think that this quote unquote
this whole trans thing
is a conservative
or liberal
thing
it's definitely the left wing
it's 100
definitely a liberal thing but yeah
it could be like for example what tends
to happen i think there's cycles of
things happen so for example if you're
too conservative like for example if
your parents are too conservative
your offspring will probably be liberal
very liberal extra liberal to the point
whereby i think it's gen z uh thought to
be the most conservative people because
they're thinking this is becoming really
really out of correct yeah so what will
happen is i think we're probably going
to have a wave of ultra conservatism in
the next
50 years or so because there's only so
much
you can divide a
um
breaker line to before it becomes
ridiculous you know so you're talking
when you talk about transracialism and
and everything so yeah so i actually do
think there is hope that
some point this is just ridiculous now
so i think it's i think it's neither
i feel like
i feel like as
i feel like the human race
the idea of thought
and curiosity or even feelings like you
said everybody has feelings in every
walk of life right i don't think i think
we're limiting what we're talking about
to western society i'm pretty sure i
don't know but like probability states
that there's somewhere in africa or
middle east or wherever there will be an
individual who wakes up every day
feeling like the opposite sex
irrespective of conservative liberty i'm
trying to say i feel like i don't want
to say it's natural i don't want to say
that but i can see
an individual just getting there without
influence or just this because i'm
talking about feelings but then just
like anyone had the feelings of feeling
like michael jackson
i think i think you you posed an ins you
posed an interesting point when you were
talking about authoritarian parents yeah
i think for the parents watching this
they might actually be very confused how
how would how would we recommend they go
about
their children that may be going through
this in a way that's supportive rather
than harmful because if they are too
authoritarian and they're like actually
no no you can't do this absolutely not
like you said there will be that
that over control will lead to over
rebellion
so
how
but at the same time if you're too if
you if you're too lenient and whatnot
that there can be so much damage and
harm in that as well so how do parents
go about it i think give them one second
give them statistics yeah if they're
it's a good question
if they're of an age where they can
understand you know basic maths and you
know can percentages and things like
that
um
89 of people that go through
transitioning regret it
yeah and the suicide rate is heavy in
that in that demographic as well
so if you put it like that yeah you know
it's
that's that's not even like a debate
it's not like a brexit vote 5248 that is
conclusive that this is a bad idea for
you
so if that's what the figures show
because i like i like analytics i think
that they play a big part in how you can
make big decisions
um
i think that would be a good way to kind
of say to kids look so just be direct
one in three people who uh trans have
attempted to commit suicide according
according to the statistics
but to answer your question as human
beings and like anyone says no matter
how much how rational we think we are
we're more emotional than we are
rational oh yeah
yeah so i'm saying from from that
perspective you better speak for
yourself
yeah
so um
to answer your question alexa there's a
good question what do you do in that
situation
don't do anything that will have a
long-term consequence like puberty
blockers if it's a situation whereby
my
boy wants to wear dresses
mates probably let them wear the dress
because at least you know in your head
there's not going to be no long-term
consequences on their body but if you
give them puberty blockers yeah i can
make it infertile that is things so that
would be my advice today so don't you
think that it's very interesting that
you're allowed to to let children
make long-term life decisions but these
children can't even vote on what's going
on in their country yeah
yeah you know i mean because that's an
interesting point you've made there
because when you were talking about the
ultra conservatism you think it's going
to come in the next 50 years if you
actually gave children the vote say 16
year olds upwards this country would be
left wing country because you'd find
that most people that go to university
now
are all
crazy left they're not even just like
center left they're crazy left
so you'd have labor constantly come into
the fold and i mean if if it happens
today you have 600 16 year olds to vote
today
you'd have labor for 50 years not yeah
because universities are breeding this
type of ideology it's not part of
conservative society or like a general
conversation that we're having right now
it's there in the university do you
think the left are more intolerant
absolutely yeah they're a bit of an
oxymoron they've gone they've gone past
the point of being tolerant and fighting
for social justices to the point now
where if you don't agree with our
version or vision of a social justice
you are the pariah you are against us
you are racist you are transphobic
you're homophobic you're insert your
majority of here you know so it's like
you can't win now because if you do have
an opinion like we're having right now
yeah lefties would hate me watching this
they'd hate me don't hate me as well
because i'm socially conservative yeah
much like you but they would they would
say to me oh you're an uncle tom
you know you're a cop when
it's disgraceful that people can even
say that to you because the end of the
day washed your skin color yeah
and determine your determine your points
of view
i tell you why because um for the past
let's say 50 60 years
black people have been thought of to be
liberal
right
and black people have voted especially
in america they voted democrat rather
than republican not really realizing
that the democrats were the original
party of the kkk right do you know what
i mean so
um i think black people
generally tend to think that we are
supposed to be liberal yeah
right we're supposed to be liberal and
conservatism is reserved for white
people that that's what i personally
think not realizing i was saying um i
was saying even before if you go back
outside of the western world to africa
black people are conservative socially
conservative they're socially
conservative generally yeah okay but in
the when black people get to the west
they become very
liberal do you know what i mean and so
when a liberal bla when a conservative
black person enters the space
of the western world right they get
called like you just said uncle tom
white supremacist [ __ ] all this kind of
stuff because black people in the west
and west are not used to
i guess black original thought in africa
you know which was quite conservative so
i think that's the reason why you get
called because i get called it too do
you know what i mean i've been called
[ __ ] uncle john i'm like listen when we
go back to who we were prior to the
western world we were quite conservative
people like what the hell like you're
from
morocco yeah so you know that
the arabic culture is probably quite
conservative
right so when you come here and they're
like oh you're not a real this you're
black yeah
i don't know it's just how do you feel
with that like personally like does it
bother you that you get called uncle tom
or it doesn't bother me now i mean it
used to because i used to be i used to
be a liberal
like i grew up liberal yeah do you know
what i mean like because i didn't know
anything else i was black in the western
world i was told to be liberal do you
know i mean it's not until i started
doing stuff and research for myself jess
can probably like
vouch for this right you started doing
research for yourself you started
realizing hang on a minute yeah certain
things don't make sense and i'm black
and i've been and that's when you
realize you've been told what to think
yeah you've been told how to feel you've
been told who to hate and who to love do
you know what i mean it's not until you
kind of like start doing it for yourself
do you realize actually no i'm actually
quite conservative you know what i mean
so
now getting called you know [ __ ] or
uncle tom it's like a badge of honor now
and it's so called the white liberals
that will say um for majority rights and
you know for black people having their
say but you go against the narrative
shut up [ __ ] shut up edward yeah
literally there's white liberals yeah
it's like the authenticity of your
blackness is diminished because you have
a different point of view yeah 100 i
think whilst we're talking about
cultural and political differences yeah
um it makes me think about one of the
first questions you ask about whether
the transgender community are
bullyingists and i think one thing that
one argument that's been used against
the lgbtq plus community as a whole is
that they often force their beliefs upon
other people yeah so
if you are someone who does not agree
with their beliefs um
the same way religious people might not
agree with each other's beliefs
how do you
disagree
in a way that isn't offensive or
disrespectful i think what it is that's
a good question i think it comes to this
notion hurt people hurt other people so
what happens is they're in a they're in
the state of fight or flux so any sort
of disagreement
they think it's an attack on their
identity i'm just trying to be
charitable i'm not saying i agree with
this notion i'm just trying to be
charitable for them so if they're grew
up in a very very
conservative home whereby everything
into the max okay they were called every
single slur under the sun the f word and
stuff like that the other f word and all
of a sudden now someone who's socially
conservative even though it's tolerant
to say you know what i know you're gay
we can still be friends but i disagree
with this because of xyz they're always
going to see it as i said because their
brain is flight or flight mode
that's me trying to be charitable
towards them i'll say i agree with it
that notion you know i'd say i'd say the
lbgtq community
if you use their own logic
they can't exist and when i say that i
mean this
the l in lbgtq means what lesbian right
okay and a lesbian is what a woman
woman right about women but i can be a
woman
don't even get me started right so if i
can be a woman
that means i can be a lesbian
can i really be a lesbian yeah
what does the g mean
gay what's gay two men but the ma but
men can now be women
so what's gay but it's not supposed to
it's not supposed to be socially
coherent
so using their own logic
the lbgtq community doesn't even make
any damn sense yeah but it's not
supposed to be socially cohesion it's
not supposed to make you feel good not
necessarily so
be logically consistent so it's
validation yeah one issue i have with
the acronym is that what does the lgb
have to do with the t
the same and i can uh give you a
parallel sounds like that sounds like
dave chappelle but go on no but no it's
true though but because i'll give you a
parallel
when it comes to um culture and race
what does b-a-m-a what does a black man
have in common with an asian person and
why are you boxed into the same box i
agree acronym there because
realistically i've got no idea what it's
like to be black i never will even if i
get stupid in this debate and say that
just identify
you i could never understand what it's
like to be a black person ever i think
what it is to answer your question it's
a good question it's a bit like similar
what happened in the second world war
did the
did the alliance and russia have
anything in common
not really they had a common enemy in
fighting obviously hitler yes hitler was
defeated
it's like
yeah that's what's happening with the
lgbt community they have a forced
alliance to say we have a common enemy
and that's the conservative so who is
the enemy though because when you think
about it
the conservative whites yeah but the
thing is though conservative white men
voted for gay marriage so when you're
boxing the lgbt
mm-hmm what does the tf do you have to
create they have to create a boogeyman
to rally people because like i mentioned
before most people are mostly emotional
than rational
i know but when you think about you
using the word conservative and you look
at historical examples more
conservatives fought to end
slavery they thought they fought in the
civil war they were they were pro-ending
slavery in america you've got
conservatives voting for gay marriage in
england like i don't really understand
why conservative-minded individuals i
mean conservatives did i mean if you
talk about slavery you're talking about
william wilberforce who was a
conservative but he he was abnormally
against the conservative party at that
time because he was one amongst many
what i'm saying is i'm giving like a big
big example of how conservative mindsets
have actually improved things and i
don't understand why minority groups and
i don't like that phrase by the way use
that as a scapegoat of saying which
conservative white men i don't really
see that i actually think white people
have got a lot more compassion than what
we're given credit for actually when it
comes to what some groups like to
portray us as
it's i i see your point i think like i
said it's narrative narrative sales not
necessarily cohe logical arguments so
it's narrative that sells and if you
tell a good story people believe it more
than they believe
without this when you talk about white
people
is racism
right
colonialism
slavery
all that kind of stuff yeah
it's it's the history of white people
right and so
it's a hit it's a history of white
nations
so what happens is like um any was
saying before what's what's more
impactful the earthquake or the actual
aftershock right so people so people
will will associate
whiteness
with
slavery oppression oppression
colonization all this kind of stuff i
don't believe all white people are
racist i really don't but does racism
exist yes it does do racist people exist
yes they do
um and so the whole thing is is that
when it happens for instance i've spoken
on like the whole blm movement that kind
of i know we're going off but we'll go
back on um i've spoken on the whole blm
movement etc etc and i've never
never as a black person i've never
supported blm
right so
because i i saw the co i saw the actual
i saw it for what it was i was like this
is like a scam you know what i mean i
mean only candice owens now is coming
out and saying that it's actually a scam
do you know what i mean because she's
done the research but i'm saying the
reason why is because the unfortunate
history of of of white people is that
you have a history of that
and it's and i'm not saying it's your
fault but i'm saying it is what it is do
you think the answer is you're really a
question about why you have
um black people being more liberal in
the western countries because there is a
historical hangover that is prevalent in
american and british society from
history
100 i think i think black people i think
all peoples
are a product of their history oh i have
a question do you think should define
you though no because i don't because
but the thing is what happens is that
people get into ruts
people just get into oh my mom did this
so i'm gonna do it or my grandma did
this so i'm gonna do it that's why if
you the reason why people vote people of
black people in america have voted
democrat consistently for the past 50
years yeah why because their grandmother
yeah yeah there's the words and their
mom did it yeah i feel you yeah there's
a word for it and i listen to a podcast
it's called generational trauma so
that's probably why we explain some of
the
thinking behind why black people vote
democrat because
you know even though if you look at on
paper it was the republican who was the
anti-slavery party
but obviously and it was the democrats
there obviously from the kkk and stuff
but because what the media tell us i
think oh
yeah
yeah
about majority demographics as well
because because white people
have or did
industrialize slavery but white people
didn't start slavery no arabs did yeah
yeah and i know that i don't know that
because i researched it
after watching one of mr garvey's videos
yeah that's it and i went and looked it
up and i was like this is kind of like
blowing my mind a little bit that
actually it started off yeah in tribes
yeah selling
black people around and then arabs
coming in and then just
you know and again it backs up again
about people being
very devilish and very fundamentally
yeah see that there's a human nature
yeah that's it oh it's in human nature
i wanted to ask a question so when we're
talking about histories and we're
talking about whether they define us or
not um for people
like so let's say for example for white
people um
but they feel really passionate about um
black people and their rights and their
issues and things like that or someone
who isn't transgender but they really
feel um so passionate about their issues
and things that they go through do you
think
people who are not a part of that
community
or haven't faced those struggles
themselves can fully advocate
[Music]
stupid of me to say you're not black
you've never experienced it so you can't
really be an advocate
the more allies you have the better
mm-hmm hence the lgbtq because the l the
g and the b's
yeah don't necessarily identify or
understand right the the trends and
whatever else but yeah the common allies
you have
you know the more you can push your
movement forward and then i think it's a
great question you've asked but i think
it also highlights how divisive society
is right now yeah that you need to ask
that question
because you know like i said a moment
ago i don't know what it's like to be
gay black whatever
but i wouldn't want anyone to hurt you
yeah and i wouldn't want anyone to take
away your rights as a human being
exactly but i can't relate to whatever
you've been through because you're black
or because you are gay yeah but i would
still want you to be okay you know what
i mean i don't understand but i stand
with you yeah yeah exactly and i think
like you've mentioned a few times now it
must be the word of the show majority
demographics you're not you ain't going
to change anything in england without
white people yeah
yeah you know or straight people because
i'm sure there's more straight white
people than there are anything else
and i think it's the language you use
like for example i was mentioning before
before the show we have a tendency to
talk at people instead of talking to
people there is a difference talking at
people saying you're racist you're a
white privileged male you know you must
apologize for what your ancestors do
you're not going to get anyone anywhere
with that attitude if you spoke to me
that way i'm going to say f off yeah but
he said if you talk to someone and say
this is what we mean by it you know and
define it because i think sometimes we
get lost in the
the terminology i don't like the word
white privilege because i just think
it's such a yeah yeah i think majority
privilege is probably a better way so
the person you're trying to
speak to doesn't feel attacked can
listen and maybe
process it and understand
connection sorry
um how do we deal with ignorant people
because um ignorance
i'm joking folks i'm just joking i'm
joking please don't don't do that they
can often be very harmful to society
yeah it's easy to say okay yeah cool if
someone doesn't agree just let them be
but a lot of the times people's opinions
can actually end up being really harmful
to society so how do we if they get into
power right so how do we deal with
people who are ignorant do we just i
think i i think education yeah it's
education but the thing is um even going
along this this subject matter i think
this conversation is educational right
right and so if we were to have and we
have had people who have opposing views
right
i think when it comes to the left side
of
the agenda
they are less willing to have the
conversation
and i've seen when it comes to the
transgender um argument i have seen the
left just shout try to shout people down
just try to disrespect people don't even
let people have a conversation you're a
transphobe you're an ex-wife like you're
this you're that you're this you and
it's like
how do we have a conversation about this
without the shouting because i think
people who
who want to understand
and maybe who don't understand
want to have a conversation about it
i've noticed that the people who are
so i've said the left have become the
fascists of nowaday
like they've been because fascism is
like shouting people down you can only
do this totalitarianism
you you shut down all forms of education
on it it is what it is and i've found
that the left
is doing that more so to conservatives
because people that was like a
conservative thing to do but i've found
that the left is doing that more so than
than the conservatives though so yeah
education how do you
have what do we do with ignorant people
then then you can kill him
i would sometimes say that also forming
relationships with people i don't know
if you've heard of daryl davis
that guy who formed him
no he's the one that he's a black guy
but he was the one that was speaking to
the kkk
and i think sometimes forming the
relationship can bring powerful can be
powerful than just giving logical
arguments because people don't care what
you know unless they know that you care
exactly so if you come in if you come
into a situation already
ready to go against somebody because
they're already ready to go against you
but when you come into a situation and
you're willing to talk about what it is
and see them for not who they are
whatever see them as a human being then
people are more willing to
have that uh conversation about whatever
it is i feel like within that community
they always they already have to
fight against people in their head that
doesn't respect them for their pronouns
and respect them for the choice that
they made and it's harder for them to
come into um a conversation without them
thinking someone's already going to be
attacking them exactly and so if you
come into the conversation
respecting or just like wanting to know
them as a person then they're more
willing to have that conversation with
people who may not understand it but
they see that as a human being so can i
ask a woman here because i'm not a woman
what what is it to be honest
i mean yeah
i was like i thought you were a girl
obviously
i was just i was just checking to see if
you guys remember my pronouns
that's all i was in as women yeah
us as women right
us as women what do we feel like it is
to be a woman
what is womanhood to you wow
i don't know having periods every month
hang on go on having periods every month
but what if there's there's some women
who don't have periods oh someone could
get rid of their parents yeah true
and but maybe talking of a majority
so is it just
biological physical yeah what is it to
be a woman because it's biological
because yeah because
as you know
because i feel like men in this trans
movement are encroaching upon womanhood
i feel like it's for women to push back
and say no this is what it actually is
to be a woman this might be a good
question this might be a good time to
illustrate a difference is there a
difference between gender and sex
there is by definition
they're they're tired i think they're
tied together
i believe you can't
yeah they're connected you can't have
sex without the agenda
x y chromosomes exist and xx chromosomes
exist i thought i was thought gender was
something to do with language like
agenda in terms of like you know in
french there's the you can express the
things in the masculine or the feminine
yeah yeah yeah but of course
for literature not for
but what is womanhood to you though like
what is womanhood just like what is it
i don't know it's all it's just
it's like easy but hard at the same time
because you don't want to suggest it
subjectify it to oh or you can um
have babies this that in the third
because there's gonna be women that are
gonna look at you as like well am i not
in my is my womanhood taken away from me
because i can't have a child but if we
were to break everything down into
our dna it would come down to that and
then the anatomy we have as women that's
something that you cannot
right now you cannot add to um you
cannot change your dna you cannot add to
your body a uterus a womb the female you
can't know
show me i'm just saying they're doing it
like they're doing like
womb transplants
when it works let me know
i'm actually so surprised that the three
of you actually struggled to answer that
question like straight off the bat you
know what it is you know what it is i'm
still young i'm 18. okay cool fine you
can all come for me i'm a baby
but like
even like i've never been able to answer
that question
do you know why
do you know what i think and please
excuse me if i'm wrong
because you just live it
it's just you it's just yeah you don't
even you don't think about it exactly
yeah even think about it right what what
what is me right but i think especially
now when we're talking about all these
different identities and what people
classify as what it's hard like it's
hard to know okay what
does a woman look like yeah i think even
when we were talking about the masculine
and feminine energy this is why i kept
asking you what does a masculine or
feminine energy look like because
nowadays it's so subjective it's not one
simple definition
it's definitely a vibe i think it's no
longer just as simple as okay yes your
biological features nowadays everywhere
you go there'll be different definitions
of a woman of a masculine or feminine or
of a man and it's like well i don't
really know what i am supposed i'm just
trying to do my best so then all jokes
aside me being pearl
all jokes aside if i was to grow my hair
get breast implants
remove my penis
and get that operation
would as a woman
would you consider me a woman
um
to respect you
yes to respect your decision that you
made
yes but it would
it would be
like when i do see
men that have transitioned into being a
woman i'm like okay great that was your
choice but it it hurts because it's like
is it that easy to become right a woman
and you don't have to go through the
pain of it i'll also give you a simple
example as well so for example if you go
to morocco right there's a tradition
that you need to go to hema if you know
what hama means so just like
everyone gets the bath to like have a
bath together like all women are for
example for community will have a bar
together it's just like a thing i might
want to go to hammer
just to watch guys just to watch i'm
just saying
right so as per what you said and you
just
transform yourself put a transplant
everything
i wouldn't feel comfortable going with
you to the hammer knowing that you are a
transgender woman
right but that's why you just said you
accept him
i will accept you i will respect you but
at the same time i wouldn't feel
comfortable with you to do some stuff
for you
she would accept
who
she is now
but you are still not a biological woman
have you noticed that women find it
harder yeah have you noticed that women
find it harder to yeah to just tell it
the way it is i was genuinely grimacing
when you guys said
like well yeah to respect you i'm like
oh you saw my face i was like yeah like
how can you say that
if if he if you genuinely decided to
transition
how is that bothering me
if this if this individual decided to be
a woman today it doesn't affect my life
but just to go on trying to say
many things won't affect your life but
you look at it from the from the
perspective of where is society going i
think everyone cares about society
that's why it has to be regulated
and with with what they were just
talking about there has to be a uh um
what was it hema yeah a hemo for natural
born women right and him that's not
inclusive bro it doesn't have to be
inclusive but we're not respect we're
respecting genders just like you can't
say inclusivity and be like well men and
women should be together in in
sarah is now sarah
sorry
being inclusive of most i wouldn't say
everything but most things i don't think
there's anything wrong with anybody
transitioning as long as it's regulated
but we are part of society yeah yeah
we've got three ladies here that
couldn't no we have a straight answer
we've got four ladies
to the idea of the concept or why is it
offensive i could tell you right now
what a man is i i could actually
probably give a better idea
that's the thing with men yeah yeah men
understand their manhood yeah right and
we always understand our manhood because
with our manhood right we
it's it's like a it's just a
psychological thing like it's innate we
know what it is if a bunch of women
today
started transitioning and saying yeah
we're men
no you ain't no period no
hell no you ain't whereas women have
tended to accept men transitioning into
women saying we're women like oh well
you know what if you feel like that then
it's fine and that's the difference
between men and women because men are
going to tell it straight down the line
how it is and i feel like you see you
talking about regulate
it's for men to regulate it and i've
said before i actually feel like
men of this of this time are doing the
job that i personally feel yeah women
should be doing because women should be
checking over with these guys yeah yeah
yeah saying you ain't no woman yeah
right but you can't comment you can't
come into my thing saying that yo
because i know what it is
because i know men would do that we
would do but like these bunch of women
coming to say that no no no no no no
push back on that one is that you have
to remember what these ladies just
demonstrated is their
disagreeableness
or
bonus yeah exactly because they would
rather
not offend and tell the truth that's
right i think there's a there's a saying
that says
truth not love without truth is
sentimentality but truth without love is
harshness
so we
they've got love without truth is
sentimental you're saying nature is that
it's this
in general not all women are like this
but most women in general
could rather say you know i'd rather
keep the relationship it's good for
society for that to have that yeah but
like you mentioned as men we will say
yeah
going back to one of
his points he mentioned in that um
you were talking about uh respect you
were saying if it doesn't bother me yeah
then i have no problem respecting you i
think that makes sense i feel like if
i'm not being harmed i think when it
comes to the toilet discussion i
personally wouldn't feel comfortable
yeah and in that case when it comes to
the discussion exactly exactly i would
not feel comfortable in that case i
would actually you know what
respectfully no not happening
when it comes to sports however if it's
just a case of okay you transitioning
that does not personally affect me that
doesn't personally harm me that doesn't
personally cause me discomfort so i can
respect you yes you're an athlete
leah thomas
we've spoken about it before yes we have
the man who now is a swimmer became the
swimmer beat all of the female swimmers
yes
biological male biological male that's
the correct term is a man biological
male okay um that went into the swimming
competition but how would how do you
feel as an athlete for that to happen so
you kept bringing up that needs to be
regulated that is one of the areas that
i think
that it
has to be regulated like there's no if
ands or buts about it if you are going
to transition if there is not a specific
team that you can play on that is
your specific demographic because that
right now that's what it is you're a
specific demographic you are born a
woman and you're still a woman you're
born a male and you're still a male
that's the demographic of the team you
can play on
i do not think that they should
intermingle
the um
the the people who are transitioning
trans man or trans women because there
are
biological differences
that are going to forever be like that
because of just what
a man gets when he is his dna is
transformed into a man and what a woman
gets between the um the hormones but
we're all equal
if we were all if we were all equal
across the board there wouldn't there
would not need there would not need to
be a need for um
male or female at all we were the same
also i also think that we're all equal
until it suits you as women and i'll
explain this i know i don't mean that in
a general term i really mean that in
like things that you've just stated you
stated that it's okay for someone to
transition because it doesn't affect you
but you've also stated that oh if i go
to the toilet i'm probably going to feel
uncomfortable
or if i'm in a pool with a biological
male i'm going to feel uncomfortable
there's a contradiction in what you said
because
the first instant of the person
transitioning it doesn't affect you
necessarily right there and then right
but the aftermath the effects that it
has in society will directly impact the
and affect you guys exactly the effect
it has in society is based on what
society is allowing the effects to be
because if
if let's say half
if half of all males in the western
um civilization decided to transition
and society said you're going to have
your own toilets there will be no
effects there'll be zero effects if you
regulate it period do you go into this
there are effects because we're we're
letting anything and everything happen
we're allowing uh um um transitioned
men to say to share toilets with natural
borne women societies well whoever's
allowing it is allowing it
so when you say effect i don't think
it's it's not a natural effect it's not
something that's just
happening it's something that's being
allowed to happen
if i start a fight
yeah if i start a fire can i control
how it can where the fire is gonna go it
goes yes
can i do can i you can't
what i wanna
put forth to you is the idea that
although you may try to
there will be other avenues where that
fire will go ablaze even if you try to
try to society's already regulated
there's certain things i can't just walk
into the women's toilets yes you can i
mean i can't i mean if but it's already
there there's structures in place like
the government has a lot of structures
in places already regulated and we're
saying they're not working
they need they need to do a better they
just need to be strict with it
you can only like
regulate it from the root you need to
stop it from the root you need to knit
you need to nip it in the bud like
but i have a clear distinction this is
this can't be happening this can be
happening yeah by allowing people to
pick and choose when they do certain
things such as like the transgender
movement okay if i've become a woman i'm
now allowed to do this or
you should have rules to say no yeah
yeah
but if you do you're a trans folk yeah
but you're a transfer because we're
allowing that term to stick like
but what you're saying is you're saying
if it doesn't affect me let it go
but then you're talking about regulate
yeah and i can't get ahead around
what i'm saying
so if you if if you decide to transition
that's cool
you can't then dictate what your
transition means to society and we can't
just say okay cool yeah that's what it
means and we're gonna accept that that's
what's happening but that's what that's
why is it happening that's my point like
why is it happening i think what's
happening is people are scared to be
heroes i think what happens is if you
want to be a hero you won't get the
glory now you'll get the glory in future
so for example every hero that we
worship and figure look at nelson
mandela yeah william wallace yeah um uh
william tyndale or they were crazy as
soon as they started
years later that we go oh if i was in
that time i would have stood by william
wallace and all the people that wanted
to end slavery trust me if you were if
you were living at that time when they
wanted to end slavery like william
wilberforce he was the mp that tried to
end slavery in the 1700s can i just can
i just give you some context because it
wasn't just really movable yeah it was
also oliver equiano who was actually a
nigerian yeah exactly just to give some
context because there were black people
involved too so all i'm saying is that
you know a lot of people say if i was
living in that time i would have been
one of those people that would have
stood up against the the
the um consensus that slavery was okay
in fact a lot of people were arguing
that the slaves like to be slaves yeah
yeah so i'm just saying it's incredible
yeah but then jordan peterson actually
said most people think
that during the time of hitler
that they would have been on the side of
the jews
no they would have been nazis yeah
yeah i agree with
isha's point where he was talking about
okay so you're saying um tackle the
issue at the root cause so in this case
people transitioning into different
genders i don't think that's an issue
let me learn let me know
yes so
where i'm trying to go with this is that
okay if we're talking about okay
tackling from
so let's say we don't allow people to
transition
what do you think is better people
identifying as a gender or people
transitioning into agenda because
there's problems with both
so
do we prefer someone just going around
saying i'm a man i'm a woman i'm not
transitioning because apparently it's
going to be a problem to you but um so
is it easier for me to just identify as
someone and go about my business there
or is it easier for me to transition
instead
i think the issue comes into play when
i'm in an institute and i'm now being
told
i have to address you as they or she
yeah and it's being frowned upon
by
i'd say the higher the higher powers
that be that will then implicate
um repercussions on the companies for
the views that
i may hold for not wanting to believe in
your rhetoric
um it's
i i'd say
i can't take you seriously
if you ain't snipped
because
you know how serious you've got to be as
a man to take your [ __ ]
like you gotta be like you gotta be
serious about your thing to get rid of
them
do you go what i'm saying like
if you haven't snipped
i ain't taking you seriously yeah just
like as a woman
yes
yeah you're trying something because
you're confused i have courage
as a man i believe i have
you know all of these things you know
how much courage it must take as a man
to take your balls off mm-hmm
that's how i know you're generally
you're serious about your feelings you
know what respect you know i'm saying
like you get my respect you're serious
about your thing i think i think the
root cause issues is the regulation
that's that's that's the main
that's that's what it boils down to if
it's if it's loosely regulated or
regulated in favor of of
of
the community then the rest of societies
is going to be impacted but there's it's
just poor regulation because there's no
way you can tell me there are states in
america who are making decisions on
women's bodies
and that's where deciding you can't have
abortions but you can't regulate that
it's not a debate no no i know but what
i'm saying is they are regulating that
irrespective of
of what women want do you go on trying
to say so
you can regulate are you are you
pro-choice so what is there yeah okay
but i'm saying there are states that are
not pro-choice and that is the law in
those states but you're finding it hard
to to stop transitioned men or women
from sharing toilets with
biologically bored men and women how is
how do you go on chinese because
like
like charlie was saying there must be a
a link between the political and and the
military right there has to be yeah
yeah everything everything that you go
through is to do with politics and money
when you think about it yeah you touched
on plm i won't go too far in that but
that i called that george soros
for that obviously right um
you know that was about that was about
money for real yeah
and then you've got the covered pandemic
yeah if that wasn't about money and
control i don't know what was oh okay so
when you think about it
how much money has been moved around the
world due to things such as those
but again i can't really work out where
the money is going with this yet yeah
one thing i noticed that every year you
get these big corporations like apple
mercedes-benz
bmw sony they'll put rainbow
uh things over their logos in western
countries they won't do it in places
like morocco
in saudi arabia because but who are they
pandering to to the community what
community
most people yeah like
i feel you but
most people most people don't agree it
means
um
we're gonna get back we've got some
super chats to read again
um
we've got ultra here on two pounds
jpt
like jpt that bum bum hot eyes
men can't get preggers did someone show
their bum bum
[Music]
um
just human 20
i get transgenderism in the binary i
don't get the other genders gender is a
social construct yes
but it points to truths in reality i
don't get that i don't get what
g
and jim is rooted in
or how could you get how could you tell
what it feels to be like it i don't know
what g and jim is there are pronouns
what the i thought was japanese or
something
these are chinese or something these are
neo pronouns
that's crazy all right we've got caleb
james
449 super chat the this ideology is
being funded by china and russia so
instead of going to war they can
brainwash the population and destroy us
from the inside oh
that's a conspiracy that i ain't heard
before better watch out the fbi
courtney harris 20
um identity confusion promiscuity fight
for abortion welfare state hookup
culture divorce etc these are all being
pushed to attack the nuclear family end
game is the weak family weak people
government reliance and loyalty wow
interesting and boss uh two dollars says
i identify as pearl and my pronouns are
sar and raw
to the woman in the center yes
how would you feel
to lose out on a college scholarship to
a transgender woman specifically for a
woman
um
bowl said to pound super chat sarah are
you red peeled
hell yeah i guess so
um nicc five pounds says what do you
think of the argument that trans women
should go to female prisons because um
sar is more common
in a male prison
s a
sexual okay okay i get you because a
sexual assault is more common in the
male prison and trans women would be
targets hmm boss five pound super chat
no amount of surgery can make a
biological man a biological woman and
vice versa let's stop the nonsense
social decay hashtag dragon stallion ten
dollars again men versus women different
muscular muscle
different bone structure different brain
structure different chromosomes
false to two pounds
woman is an adult human with an x x
chromosome pair
simple dragon stallion 10 again people
are donating thank you very much thank
you very much
thank you very much it's going all
towards the equipment ten dollars
there are three middle school kids 10 to
14 years old that are being sued for
sexual harassment for not using
another student's preferred pronouns
[Music]
last one dragon silence 10 to the woman
in the center
oh no we read that one how would you
feel to lose yeah that concludes the
super chats thank you everybody wow okay
um thank you for the super chats guys
all going to the uh equipment once again
um and yeah appreciate you
so um what do you think about what was
just said about um people being sued now
for not
again that's poor regulation
why would that be allowed
it's just with the land i guess you're
the the term you coined toxic tolerance
tolerance like
you can accept people for whatever they
feel whatever they believe whatever it
is however what you believe cannot um
impact somebody else who's
opposite to them who's opposing to your
views and ideologies yeah but the
argument but the argument is that once
you've allowed this to happen these are
the after effects it's a bit like if
there was a nuclear bomb put
set off somewhere it's not necessarily
the bomb that's going to cause the
monster effect it's the aftershocks it's
directed
then you have to answer you have to
answer i understand after effects and
aftershock and and if you allow this
then the the the shock
yeah i understand that but i will use
the abortion as an example because
there's no or where it started where it
ended men are saying women
because when you said something i went
oh a minute ago because you missed about
beliefs yeah you can't force your
beliefs on other people you've mentioned
abortion and in the context of america
that's also religion
yeah yeah true so in in effect you can
actually enforce your beliefs
yeah i'm using the via the law obviously
yeah so kind of kind of i should say you
shouldn't force no you definitely
shouldn't but
i'm more coming along to your viewpoint
of regulation i get i get more as you
keep talking i get more and more what
you're trying to get across
i just don't really understand how you
can
do it when
you've already got politicians brought
in and one thing that i know about
politicians is that when they double
down on something yeah
they'll never
they'll never get up their ground
because it makes them look weak as
politicians and if the politician admits
that they're wrong
their credibility falls through the
floor and that's what they're all afraid
of yeah it's so fickle
so
when you've got like people in this
country you mentioned prisons you had
during the leadership campaign for the
labour leader when jeremy corbyn stepped
down
you had
lisa nandy i believe go and do a a rally
somewhere and said that if a biological
man transgender woman was convicted of
rape would you let that person go into a
female jail and she's great and she said
rape grape my apologies no problem she
said she said yeah i'll put them in they
can go in a female prison now i shared
something on my instagram a little while
ago i think it was american news but
it's still relevant it can happen here
um
where a man a biological man as a
transgender woman went to prison
had lots of illegal fun yeah
and and got two people pregnant exactly
that yeah exactly that yeah and got two
people pregnant
so i think it does take strong
individuals to go do you know what we've
had enough of this but you're not going
to get that from the political class
because i've always never done it the
system does not make sense as we were
talking about earlier
young people under the age of
in in england under age of 18 cannot
vote you're assuming 10 to 14 year olds
exactly for making certain decisions
labeling as sexual harassment but they
can't make other decisions yeah by the
way legally i don't think they're suing
the the children i know i know but i'm
saying how it's for the decisions of
their children but they aren't legally
allowed to make decisions themselves so
how is that making sense
and how is it
that sexual harassment right when
there's nothing sexual that has to do
with it that's what's blowing my mind
how can you classify something so that's
the question like does transgenderism
bring in a sexual element
like identity
is identity i'm a man there's no sexual
element in there
so why does transgender have a sexual
element
because there's no nobody's regulating
it everybody's just accepting what it is
not to
offend them essentially they're just
this culture nowadays has become
upset oh goodness can't talk uh
like how do you say it i can't say a
sexual element no no except accept it
goodness i couldn't say that yes
accepting
of
just things that have this culture
nowadays as nobody's like questioning it
logically that's just like oh you say
that sexual harassment against you
because they got their prone because
they got your pronouns wrong okay yes it
is we don't want to offend you anymore
we don't want anything come against us
so we're going to take your word for it
instead of logically thinking about it
that's not sexual harassment they just
forgot how to say your pronouns
correctly they probably forgot what they
ate for breakfast this morning
i think it's conflation of the grouping
you know earlier on i said lgbt yeah
the lgb part is sexual the tea party
isn't yeah and i think you have the
conflation now yeah
so i think that's probably where you get
that but it's completely backwards but
that's the way i'm can we also talk
about non-binary because where does
non-binary come into all of this i don't
really understand how that works how can
you not
be agenda
because you feel that way because i
remember watching a thing on british
news and on british tv about when piers
morgan was on there and he was talking
about there was a guy and i said now
there are there are a hundred genders
have you guys seen a video there were
100 genders and some of them were like
wisp gender and
you feel wispily and
whatever it was right and pierce was
like stop the [ __ ]
you know basically it's like stop the bs
so like i said going back to what was
saying earlier on is it this thing is a
feeling
and my whole thing is when did feelings
start to trump factual information
like because i always said when when
when does a transgender stop because
um the trans train stopped because
there's a guy in um
holland a couple of years ago called
emil rattleband
right
and emile rattleband
was a 70 year old man
and he said he felt more in his 40s
and then he said he wanted to transit he
wanted to be quote unquote trans age and
he went to court he lost the case by the
way
but the fact that he said he wanted to
be younger
than his actual age to me now says
there's now going to be in the future an
argument for people wanting to be
a different age
and that's what i said so imagine now
there's a man who says
so say they say trans age is a thing now
you can identify someone younger
if a man identifies as younger
and a child identifies as older
and they get into a relationship
now oh god there's an example now
pedophilia and home
there's a man in canada he's uh he was
married with three kids
and literally transitioned not only to a
to a woman to a little girl
claims up to five years old and was
adopted by two parents it's actually on
youtube typing canada trans uh trans man
child on youtube oh for goodness sake
what is it where is
the train stop where does it stop what
does it start yeah where does it stop
like
yeah
and now
when you find where the money is yeah
that's my that's my
genuine belief
i like charlie talking about you talking
about where the money is
who's benefiting from it because i don't
understand how these
regulations are all the rules and accept
it i don't understand where it's coming
from and why it's being accepted
confusing what needs to happen there
needs to be a sort of a william wallace
sort of figure that's willing to take
all the accusations all the thing
because i rather suffer for my future
generation to live in peace if it means
that i'm gonna get all the flack i need
to get so be it but that was that was
peace
that was kevin samuels yeah but what
needs to happen that's what needs to
happen so there needs to be more
sacrificial lambs to see in this area
how would you get the platform for that
though
who would get the platform for that you
create your own you question your own
can you though you can you can you can't
especially with blockchain technology
you know you can that you don't have to
um be on youtube or anything you know
decentralized systems
even tonight's show you you pulled me up
for a word i shouldn't have used for the
for the algorithm right yeah
right in itself if you use that too many
times you're busted right yeah but
doesn't mean you have to be youtube but
then you have places like ghetto yeah
you have places like if you built a
following here people like youtube they
might just watch this on youtube for the
convenience i like youtube more than
anything else but i'm on i'm on rumble i
think what happened
you start to move ready
i always believe this like for example a
lot of women criticize why was kevin
samuel so popular all kevin simmons was
doing was revealing what men were
talking about in the barber shop so for
example if someone because most people
believe this is bs
but then it needs someone to willing to
say it and stand on it and people will
follow it and once he has a following
youtube reacts to money
so most more people said this is bs
youtube will change that algorithm
overnight but alex jones got shut down
and he was massive on youtube yeah but
he didn't have the
he was huge
the momentum to do that oh you're joking
so will you use it for such
david i got shut down yeah right but
david axe followers continued mm-hmm
i mean i think alex jones is doing all
right but and alex jones followers
but what i'm saying is is that
the money side of it i don't think
they're too bothered about i think it
becomes to do with like power
in your message it's like how
reactionary do people get to a tweet
so if if kevin summons a video when he
was when he was here
he's getting a hundred thousand two
hundred three hundred thousand in quick
quick time that's power in my opinion
that's influencing power yeah that's why
you want to control that position
but what i'm saying is when you finish
when you have power and influence like
that look at some controversial figures
that have been taken off platforms
you mentioned a couple joseph watson
paul joseph watson
um you've interviewed this man tommy
robinson tommy robinson off of things
yeah it doesn't you don't necessarily
have to chime with the message i'm a
free speech absolutist i believe you can
say whatever but farah khan got taken
off his
but the thing is those figures paul
joseph watson who still gets his massive
numbers yep tom robinson
i'm sure still makes a ton of
he's got a ton of influence wherever he
is farrakhan still does you know
but it's i don't think it's about money
i think it's about how influential you
can be
because when you think these are kind of
like heroical figures so it's the thing
about i said i've obvious because
wow um this whole thing about
social influences
right
um that's why i don't call myself an
influencer
i call myself an opinion former
right i think there's a difference so
people have the um the ability to form
opinions
the people that we mention that get
de-platformed
are the people that
start forming people's opinions
they're not influencers because
influencers can i don't know i'll buy a
pair of trainers oh i'll get people to
buy the trainers
it doesn't matter it's when you start to
actually start to form people's opinions
is when the quantum core powers that be
start to kind of look at you like who is
this person like what's going because
what did you you're shifting the tide
the one person that i actually feel like
is an opinion former right now we said
on youtube it's russell brand
yeah regardless of what you think of him
i think russell brand is forming
opinions and he's doing it in a way in
which and i commend him for this right
he's treading that line as to not
get cancelled or get de-platformed but
also give the information
do you know what i'm saying and that's a
fine line yeah well i was talking about
cancer culture
um where do we draw the line between
accountability and free speech
i i'll say this accountability if
someone's accountable but there's an
option for redemption
like for example if someone said
something wrong like what i don't like
is someone said something 10 years ago
and it's brought up and their counsel
they have like a old tweet or something
tweets and stuff like that but there's
no even if they apologize they don't get
any sort of chance to redeem themselves
and to work again that's when it crosses
the line right accountability it's like
okay you did something wrong you've
learned the lesson
you know you'll be a better person for
it council culture is you did something
wrong and we want you dead
can you always can you always measure
that though like how what does a a good
apology look like and at one point do we
forgive because you're not gonna sit
there and say okay cool if we're just
gonna say okay influencers or whatever
people yeah you come out with your great
apology lovely stuff okay move on
there's no accountability but at the
same time if we go with cancer culture
there's the other extreme where it's
like
okay well
you're just gonna get cancelled you're
gonna be removed no i think there's
difference in like the apology thing do
you know i mean i think there's like
someone today could get caught with a
racist tweet or whatever right and then
apologize my whole thing is no you know
what
when people
reveal who they are just believe them
so you're only saying uh you're saying
your apology now because you got caught
yeah yeah because behind closed doors
this is the type of stuff you say but
when it comes to that
on the flip side i believe that every
people
have race prejudice
and we're all lying about the fact that
we do
so we understand that as black people
white people asian people arab people
behind closed doors there's some stuff
that we say that we would never say in
public do you know what i'm saying like
we all know that right but the thing is
it's the honest conversation happens
when we say you know what
can i bring that out into the public and
you bring yours out into the public and
then we have a conversation about it you
know i'm saying that can we do that
that's why that's why i think racism
will consistently um rear its ugly head
because the stuff that we have behind
closed doors we're not willing to bring
out
me personally i'm wanting to bring it
out yeah i would say you know i think
this kind of stuff sometimes can you
bring up but the thing is and i always
say that when it comes to white people
unfortunately
they think if i bring my [ __ ] out right
i'm done i'm done i think this answers
the question of whether people can
change if you don't give people the room
to change or actually learn about your
actions that's never going to happen
yeah the fact that we can sit down here
and we a lot of us may have different
opinions on different things and with
intersectionality being a thing we all
come from different cultures and
different and all different backgrounds
but we can sit down and we can have a
discussion and we're not afraid to
disagree with each other that's where
education comes in that's where the room
for change can come in if we're just
gonna go with cancer culture and say
okay cool you've done this wrong we can
all agree it's wrong get out leave
okay they can apologize they can write
all the best apologies in the world they
can hire writers they can hire marketing
teams whatever cool that's never going
to change like their actions or who they
are because they're not really going to
be able to see
how wrong they are
or understand where they have went wrong
and so if we actually have more
conversations and more discussions that
allows the education to take place that
allows people to see other people's
perspectives assuming
and if people are willing to have that
conversation i feel like yeah and
sometimes you know even if you do meet
someone who's racist sometimes there's a
story behind that for example yeah why
are you yeah if someone well um
you know
you know
a man
his daughter was raped by a black sorry
sorry great by a uh
great by a black uh guy could you
understand why he had that tendency
that's what we were saying earlier with
liam neeson yeah i know he was in an
interview and
he told a story about something that
happened to him
someone close to him however many years
ago and basically the lady had been
raped by somebody who was black
great jesus christ
by somebody he was black and he um he i
can't remember what tool he reached
where he grabbed the tool and he was
looking for any black person to say
something wrong to him so he can sort of
carry out the scapegoat exactly do you
know what's funny though do you know
what's interesting though about that
and i've said
that's not something that black people
do
so if one if one of our family members
was graped by a white person we would be
like i'm gonna look for any white person
to do that
that's not something that we do
that's something that comes with uh
being white they have that majority
privilege privilege
they have that that privilege that
they're able to do things that other
people can't because of them
being
in that space they're being privileged
so like you said black people wouldn't
do that because if a black person
wouldn't did that oh off them hold up
yeah
that's the only white man
i'm gonna exert some privilege
how can you say every no black person
would do that you don't know no let me
tell you something you don't you don't
know i tell you why i don't charlie yeah
black people have like a collective like
yeah
they have like a thing like we have a
collective thing it's like if an arab or
a moroccan person was to grape one of my
family i'm not looking for all moroccan
people i don't give a damn what one
again
you might i mean look i'm not saying you
will but you might even no but the thing
is you see that the shootings are
happening at buffalo shooting you had
dylan roof
like when you read their manifestos they
talk about
black people in a general in a general
term right as a community as a community
so they're like oh we wanted to get rid
of him
and
but i'm going to go somewhere deep now
but
the one thing
that a lot in my in my personal point of
view uh one thing that a lot of
white people don't get about black
people
is that we don't see them
the way they see us
generally so it's like we don't see
white people like oh we don't we don't
do mass shootings of white people
black people it's like oh because i
wanted to kill we we don't see you the
same way that some of you not all of you
see us we just don't like it's just like
we just don't see it that way
because you mentioned shootings how do
you see each other
like so we see it like and i've said
this and i said this one listen it's a
very deep one i said this black people
are more willing to shoot another black
person than they are a white person yeah
wow just to be just to be real yeah
because if you look at the statistics
most crime is interracial yeah right so
intra-racial means you're more likely to
commit a crime against someone who of
your own race black people are more
likely to do that against their own but
also it's proximity though so
you know if so that's why i said why
would we stop being scared stop being
scared of black people doing some [ __ ]
to you we ain't
we don't think like that we just don't
to a de because to a degree i feel like
it's human nature what liam neeson did
we may not all act on it but take 911
for an example
like we all looked at people from middle
east were like if if somebody who looks
arab was to get on a train we would
everyone black white asian whoever it is
we all looked at them
we decided especially if they had a
package on them so i feel like
we may not all go there but we like you
you mentioned earlier we all have racial
prejudices prejudice exactly we do we do
you know what i mean so i feel like that
was the same in the liam neeson neeson
situation we may not do it you and i or
the black community may not necessarily
feel we can or whatever but it would run
through our minds if i was that enraged
if i if my sister came from a bar and
there's only 10 men there i'm going to
the bar and in my mind any one of them
can get it so it may not be the exact
same situation as liam neeson but
it's not that we're not that far far off
from did you know did could it just be
an overreaction and
first it obviously didn't do it yeah
yeah he didn't i didn't i didn't and did
he not offer this up as like an actual
like interview that wasn't even a
question just kind of yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was so it was getting into the
psychology of what he was talking about
yeah so for me i mean i don't remember i
remember the outline of the story not in
depth but for me
that's a bit like he's angry it's an
immediate thing you're going to be angry
immediately yeah yeah you make it
emotional his mindset is obviously
warped
but the crime is also warped 100 but i'm
saying what what i'm trying to like some
and i say this a lot the one of the
things that i try to let um if i speak
to white people because you know i spoke
with tommy robinson i've spoken to like
sargon of akkad like
a lot of fear
that i feel that white people have
is that black people are going to do the
same [ __ ] to them that they've done to
us historically it's like black people
have been quote unquote free
yeah
for decades
there's no sleeper cells of black people
looking to kill white people like
i've not heard of this as a white man
i've not i've not had this like fear
projected onto me i don't think it right
but i've heard it before but the thing
is what you're in britain though yeah
right so if you look if you are scared
of black people so you look at america
and you get mass shootings like the
buffalo
like dylan roof
and and stuff of that
stuff of that ilk right where they when
when you read their manifestos and you
read their fears
right and they say black people or the
mexicans or the jews or what is that
is that white people or americans
that's white americans
okay so it's not all white people no no
of course it's not all white people i'm
just saying that
the comment you're making isn't about
british white people no i'm certain no
no i'm saying all right so we can specif
we can specify it to american white
people
american white people need to understand
that black people in america
have been there for a very long time
and they haven't been plotting and
planning and scheming against you
they've just been saying you know what
let's just do our thing leave us alone
you know i mean and so it's like i just
want
white american people you can say to
just say you know what just chill the
hell out yeah
actually i can i can agree on that
because for example if you go to france
now right especially paris
um people wouldn't tend to not talk more
to girls for example wearing a scarf
because of islamophobia that is
happening there it's a huge thing there
that
they even wanted to eradicate mosques
all over paris just because of what
happened previously and that's how they
treat what happened previously
that happened and
grapes that happened and all that you
know so people tend more to hate that
particular community even knowing that
they haven't done anything to them you
know just because of the whole mass
community that okay one muslim person
did this so maybe the whole community is
like that it's a stigma
but the thing is with that though this
is a thing about
i've always said about immigration right
um people are xenophobic a lot of people
are xenophobic by nature no matter what
color race culture you are
um
people are xenophobic and so if
something different moves in into their
territory they're more likely to be a
bit suspicious of it do you know what
i'm saying like
it's just
it's just kind of like a normal thing
and i think
especially with islam in france
that's the thing exactly especially in
that place but i i think that when
people people need to understand we talk
about cultures before earlier on right
we're saying people in like you know um
south america in the in the jungle or
whatever will have a different culture
to people outside of that i think more
so what you're getting is a culture
clash
100 and people understand that a
different culture is moving in on our
culture
we don't see things the same we don't
praise the same god we don't eat the
same food we don't and so if there's a
fear there that's what it is i think and
the change also like i was mentioning to
alexa the other day
the reason why
there seems to be a pushback is that for
example we see in nature when you change
from the seasons from winter to summer
it won't be winter tuesday and summer
the next day there's a gradual change
right in the same way with other changes
like immigration and stuff the reason
why the pushback because the change is
happening way too fast we just had you
know gay rights have the right to get
married was it 2010 i don't know yeah
that was yeah then all of a sudden now
we've got traffic now we've got
transgenderism it's way too fast then
this is where the that's where the
schism comes isn't it yeah yeah exactly
i like your analogies thank you thank
you thank you yeah it's like it's like
when things happen too fast
human beings don't get a chance to kind
of digest it yeah and understand exactly
and process it and understand exactly
what's going on when it happens like
okay today we're fine tomorrow we got
five thousand chinese people on our
borders we're like yo yeah what was
going on yeah what's going on yeah and
that's just that's the nature of human
beings but um issue we got super chats
yes
yes we do yes super chat super chat um
you just let you know paul's been in the
chat she's been yes pearl
big up she says hi i've been in the chat
yeah even though i've been having this
conversation
uh just human five dollars do we have to
hold people accountable as a whole why
can't we make the decision independently
whether we want to entertain someone or
their content okay i don't know what
that was in reference to ryan reynolds
twenty dollars didn't say anything thank
you for twen dollars
um
sam onochie 499 the guy in the red
hoodie is on point regulation is key
that's for you mane
um dragon stallion 10
you're free to say whatever you want as
long as it's not a crime or inside a
crime if people get offended just don't
listen
grow a thicker skin
and matt butcher donated just ten
dollars and say anything thank you very
much
for the money um we're to close out guys
all right we're going to close out we've
been here for like two hours and over
and thank you all for coming great
discussion
something from this from this thing here
today and before we actually get going
can you tell everyone where they can
find you okay okay so my name's my
instagram is ini1983 and you can find me
on instagram
my favorite is going to go in the mini
money mode
uh you can find me on instagram uh candy
floss chocolate muffin oh
candy floss chocolate muffins
um you can find me on
instagram it's
underscore jess you can find me on
youtube as well at it at it's your girl
jess
but just let them know that you're gonna
be hosting next week oh yeah i'll be
hosting on the first so come watch check
it out it'll be exciting
great
my name is alexa asma you can find me on
instagram anywhere as a l e k s a
a s m e
um all platforms
i'm there
you can find me instagram and underscore
i am a and e
underscore i am a and e
underscore what the [ __ ] oh sorry sorry
you can swear
and he underscore dj yeah
dj i'm changing all my socials to
chocolate hufflepuff
white chocolate
that's not nice
i'm keeping it real
dark you can find me at charlie sansome
charlie
s-a-n-s-o-m the surname
uh and you can find me at sarah garvey
on all platforms or just pearly things
seen as i've been transitioning okay
i've been transitioning so um
thank you all um it's been an
educational conversation i hope you will
learn something from it um even though
we may disagree okay we can still have
opinions and we don't wish hate or um i
guess violence upon anyone
however we do all have our opinions um
thank you everyone for joining thank you
everyone for watching thank you everyone
who donated and again
if you have watched two
or more of our videos and you haven't
subscribed then we've got beef
specifically
so subscribe right now peace everyone
[Applause]